tout ça est-ce que ça te fait dire toi
est-ce que Eric Zemmour te fait peur
alors
ce qui me fait peur non mais ce qui
m'inquiète c'est les discours que
j'entends surtout à Nice il explique
qu'il veut voter pour Éric Zemmour parce
qu'il est cash parce qu'il a grandi dans
le 9 3 OH il dit des choses mais il les
fera pas avec lui avec un autre je me
sentirais plus en sécurité en fait c'est
sur du vide concrètement que se base ta
conviction que là tu fais du cheerley
picking est en train de choisir des
morceaux de ce que je viens de dire il y
a des guillemets pour moi ce que tu as
dit non non je suis pas du tout
malhonnête sur ça et moi en fait ce que
je comprends pas c'est pourquoi
un musulman qui vote pour franchement je
suis désolé mais non c'est ouais pour
moi c'est incompatible mais c'est même
pas ça qui m'inquiète c'est qu'en fait
il a même pas de vrais arguments c'est
en face de moi j'avais un musulman qui
m'a prêté trois arguments on aurait pu
discuter mais franchement il n'a aucun
qui me convaincre j'aurais bien voulu
mais c'est convaincre mais ça marche pas
c'est vide c'est pas de pouvoir
pour le faire changer d'avis en fait bon
après j'ai pas pris ton centre de faire
changer d'avis mais tout simplement que
en fait la haine de l'autre n'est pas un
programme politique tout simplement la
guerre civile n'est pas un projet
politique le racisme c'est un délit
c'est pas une opinion et du coup un
racisme c'est un délinquant pas un
président tout simplement pour moi ça se
résume à ça moi Eric Zemmour il a des
idées dangereuses il a été condamné
c'est un métier condamné et je comprends
pas dans certains métiers on demande un
casier judiciaire vierge mais on est
tout à fait on est d'accord avec
nous-même si on est lié à un homme avec
un casier judiciaire qui a qui a été
condamné plusieurs fois pour ça a été
condamné récemment
c'est pas de sortir
aux élections
parce que tu as commencé par là et ben
moi je pense aux valeurs françaises
tu as vu en moi un voile et une famille
musulmane c'est tout ce que tu as vu
mais je suis une Française et j'ai un
cerveau dans des places à certains il y
en a qui ont pas encore attaquer ça dans
leur tête mais je suis une Française et
je réfléchis avec les valeurs françaises
c'est pour les valeurs d'un gestes et
c'est avec pardon mais qu'est-ce bref
c'est pas avec c'est pour les valeurs
françaises justement que je suis contre
Zemmour c'est pour la France et comme il
dit Monsieur Verdez j'ai mal à ma France
que j'entends tout ce que vous dites
honnêtement c'est inquiétant alors
Mathieu Delormeau deux choses la
première juste parce que je suis un
petit peu un petit peu choqué la
première déjà
l'histoire a montré que tous les pays
qui avait élu l'extrême ça c'est
toujours mal terminé ça c'est dans
l'histoire mais au-delà de ça c'est vrai
qu'on parle de la sécurité c'est
important mais pardon je parlais aussi
un tout petit peu de de de nous aussi de
ce que je représente aussi je pense
qu'on est à peu près 15% d'homosexuels
en France les femmes je rappelle que ce
monsieur est contre le marge homosexuel
il est contre la GPA il est contre la
différence il est contre l'enseignement
de la différence dans les écoles ça veut
dire que à ses yeux déjà nous on essaie
de la Constitution c'est de l'argent
et ce qui me fait le plus mal c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a ça a été un tel un
tel combat pour avancer que ce soit
contre le racisme contre l'antisémitisme
ou pour l'homosexualité que voir
qu'aujourd'hui il puisse tenir des
propos
homophobe en toute liberté et que ça ne
choque personne si en plus Jean-Michel
tu as raison tu penses que c'est 45% au
second tour ce sont des gens qui votent
par conviction alors j'ai très peur oui
j'ai très peur